[Música]
vamos a hablar de los temas de salud con
más Romero sala mar Buen día para usted
gracias Ángela Buenos días Y hoy usted
nos trae un tema basado en la lucha
contra el racismo en reportajes que se
han hecho para hablar sobre cómo este
fenómeno impacta tan gravemente la salud
de las personas Sí lo hacemos vamos a
traer este tema basándonos en una serie
de reportajes precisamente de la agencia
p que visitó varios lugares de Estados
Unidos siguiendo este tema y empezamos
por la infancia vamos a ir desde la
infancia hasta la vejez porque desde los
primeros años de vida los niños y las
niñas afro en Estados Unidos se están
quedando sin aire y es por culpa del
asma desde hardford con ética llegaba
este testimonio
la razón por la que creo que tenemos
tantos casos de asma en Hartford es por
la polución del aire tanto del tráfico
como Industrial las cifras de asma son
directamente proporcionales al
incinerador de basura el mayor indicador
de la ubicación incineradores en
Connecticut es el porcentaje de personas
afro en la comunidad
es decir están más cerca de zonas con
más contaminación ya sea por
incineradores pero también por el
tráfico por las autopistas por estar
cerca viviendo cerca de zonas
industriales pero también por temas de
vivienda no las casas en las que viven
suelen estar en peores condiciones a
raíz Pues de las desigualdades
socioeconómicas relacionadas con el
racismo más humedad y más mono vivir de
alquiler también hace que tengas menos
posibilidades de arreglar entonces de
poner solución a los problemas
estructurales de una casa también sucede
que viven en casas más viejas entonces
hay más polvo y eso también despierta
pueden ser causantes o de cosas que
despiertan el asma y al final esto no
son políticas de vivienda y urbanismo
heredadas de años y años de segregación
racial y para terminar una cifra en este
tema no la prevalencia de asma es el
doble es más del doble De hecho en niños
a los niños blancos el 12% en los niños
afro versus 5% en los niños blancos
aproximadamente y esto se llama racismo
estructural las personas
afrodescendientes ya viven el racismo
desde sus primeros años el asma puede
ser un ejemplo de ello pero hay algunos
muchísimo más extremos hay algunos más
extremos y de hecho es uno de los
motivos que muchos expertos señalan para
que luego en la adolescencia la juventud
afro también tenga más problemas de
salud mental que se reflejan en muchas
cosas no De hecho el 50% de los jóvenes
negros en Estados Unidos tienen de
depresión de moderada asevera es la
mitad es una cifra muy alta esto a que
viene pues viene por una discriminación
por ejemplo cuando son jóvenes los
adultos de su alrededor lo como los
profesores lo suelen tratar con más
dureza o como si fueran adultos cuando
todavía son pequeños también al tener
menos oportunidades de espacios de ocio
o de extraescolares por nombrar algunos
ejemplos muy puntuales y trajimos unos
datos recopilados por los cdcs sobre los
intentos de suicidio que solo la punta
del iceberg no problemas de Salud Mental
mucho más grandes pero en la población
afro pasó de ser del 8% en 2011 ser una
de las más bajas a llegar al 14% en 2021
10 años después también además son los
que menos ayuda profesional buscan y
algo puede tener que ver con que solo el
4% de los psicólogos estadounidenses se
han afro también no entonces ahí ese
miedo de sufrir discriminación o sesgos
por muy inconscientes que sean dentro de
las propias consultas Pero es que qué
más va a esperar ustedes de una persona
que crece defendiéndose de la sociedad
más claro exactamente al final eso
también tiene muchos impactos en su vida
que además tiene tiene muchas
ramificaciones ahora vamos a verlo Mire
voy a hacer una pequeña pausa aquí
porque me interesa mucho este tema que
usted está mencionando Y es que entrando
un poco digamos a la humanidad que
tenemos dentro de periodistas Pues yo
también soy mamá y me parece válido
hacer una recomendación para nuestros
televidentes Y pues también para usted
si le llama la atención porque la
plataforma de streaming Disney tiene una
serie que se llama cantar y es una serie
precisamente basada en todas estas
discriminaciones que se propician desde
la niñez y pues como combatirlas después
de esa pequeña cuña no cuña mar Pues
continuamos con el tema porque se sigue
poniendo más grave la cosa el racismo
persiste y muy fuertemente en el momento
de dar a luz sí Ángela Esta es una de
las cifras para mí más dolorosas que
traemos que ponemos hoy sobre la mesa
aquí las personas afro tienen la tasa de
mortalidad materna más alta en todo el
país en todo Estados Unidos tres veces
más que las mujeres blancas casi 70
muertes por cada 100.000 nacimientos y
se explica la mayoría de análisis la
mayoría de expertos lo explican con algo
tan básico como que no se las escucha de
la misma forma no se las tiene en cuenta
de la misma forma ape recoge la historia
de Angélica lions que estuvo semanas
diciendo que tenía dolores en el
estómago dolores abdominales que no se
encontraba bien hasta que un día con
dolor insoportable llega al hospital y
en este momento vieron que el latido del
bebé cayó se desplomó llevaron a una
emergencia a una cesárea de emergencia
casi no sobrevive la diagnostican con
sepsis Y probablemente esto se hubiera
podido ahorrar O al menos hubiera podido
ser menos grave si desde el principio se
hubieran tomado en serio esos síntomas
que ya expresaba que es verdad que
pueden ser confusos cuando es la sepsis
Se pueden confundir con los mismos
síntomas del embarazo Como por ejemplo
las náuseas pero que con un buen examen
y un buen diagnóstico se puede conseguir
esa precisión y Poco después la hermana
de Angélica también embarazada le
dijeron que tenía que iba que ir a dar a
luz Perdón al mismo hospital y esto era
justamente lo que comentaba
Mi corazón se desplomó cuando el médico
me dijo que tenía que ir al mismo
hospital porque no quería a raíz de todo
lo que ella sufrió yo estaba
traumatizada durante todo mi embarazo
pensé que no iba a sobrevivir o que mi
bebé no iba a sobrevivir
que es un claro ejemplo no este
testimonio de Esta desconfianza que se
acumula versus el sistema médico las
autoridades sanitarias cuando ves Ese
racismo a ti pero también a tus seres
más queridos En unos pocos minutos hemos
hablado de violencia de género de
violencia obstétrica de maltrato
infantil y todo esto transversal hacer
una persona afrodescendiente a partir de
este tema mar otro ejemplo claro y muy
simple además es que las personas afro
sufren una mayor presión arterial sí
Esto está especialmente relacionado a
partir no sucede a partir de los 55 años
de vida y traemos unas cifras del
porcentaje de población con esa dolencia
en la población afro es ocho puntos
porcentuales más que en las personas
blancas y también son más las son menos
Perdón las personas que tienen acceso a
medicamentos para controlar precisamente
esa presión arterial cómo lo explicamos
pues probablemente raíces en las
desigualdades económicas no algo tan
simple como la dificultad de conseguir
comida más sana y esto tiene un impacto
también más allá lo vimos con la
pandemia de covid 19 tener una presión
alta era un factor de riesgo y es uno de
los factores que explica que más
población afro falleciera un porcentaje
Más alto que población Blanca por Kobe
llegando a la vejez el alzheimer también
se vuelve un problema afecta más a las
personas afrodescendientes que a las
personas que llamamos erróneamente
blancas o caucásicas exactamente esto lo
explican puede tener un componente
genético pero también la presión alta la
diabetes el estrés crónico de como
decías años y décadas una vida entera de
remar contracorriente sabemos que son
factores que también se explican o
pueden explicar el alzheimer el 14% de
adultos mayores negros tienen esta
enfermedad versus el 10% de las personas
no racializadas Aunque puede ser que
incluso esté infradiagnosticado
precisamente por esa falta de escucha o
por esa falta de búsqueda de ayuda y de
atención médica escuchamos un testimonio
de una cuidadora también
si no la hubiera llevado a un geriátrico
estaríamos yendo y viniendo del hospital
y ahí no hubiera recibido un tratamiento
equitativo cuidadoso y cómodo
especialmente por su raza creo que parte
de mi experiencia hubiera sido bastante
distinta si fuera una persona blanca de
mediana edad o un hombre blanco me
hubieran escuchado desde el primer
momento me hubieran respetado
yo quería terminar Ángel haciendo esta
reflexión No que al final es un pez que
se muerde la cola un hijo con asma hace
que se pierda más días de escuela hace
que vaya más que sus
compañeros hace que los padres pierdan
por ejemplo días de trabajo pierdan
dinero también sucede lo que veíamos la
presión alta la relación que tiene con
el covid o con el alzheimer no la Salud
Mental como impacta la salud física o la
dificultad de encontrar un trabajo el
estrés del trauma de un embarazo que
termina así no todas estas cosas son al
final determinantes en la salud y en el
estatus socioeconómico de estas personas
y en sus vidas en la calidad de sus
vidas haciendo que al final sea muy
difícil romper ese mismo ciclo y esas
cadenas de pobreza son procesos
violentos mares son procesos
efectivamente racializados Y que no unos
hablan muy bien de Derechos Humanos no y
que tendríamos que solucionar estarlo
haciendo desde ya Bueno pues aquí está
su pequeño aporte con esta información
Gracias a usted gracias Ángela